well the US is calling for a transparent
investigation of the disappearance of a
Saudi journalist who'd been critical of
Saudi Arabia's crown prince
president Trump expressed concern
yesterday about missing Washington Post
contributor Jamal khashoggi the us-based
journalist
vanished last week in Turkey and this
morning we're learning new details about
turkeys investigation Holly Williams is
outside the Saudi consulate in Istanbul
where Khashoggi was last seen Holly good
morning good morning Saudi Arabian
journalist Jamal has Shoji entered the
Saudi consulate here in Istanbul Turkey
last Tuesday apparently to get a
document he needed to marry his Turkish
fiancee his friends say they haven't
heard from him since the Turkish Foreign
Ministry said today that Saudi Arabia
has agreed to allow
Turkish investigators to search inside
the consulate building her Shoji's
supporters protested outside the Saudi
consulate today demanding to know his
whereabouts this image is said to be
taken from a CCTV camera showing her
Shoji entering the consulate on Tuesday
we can't independently verify it Turkish
officials speaking anonymously have told
journalists they believe her Shoji was
murdered inside the Saudi consulate but
they've so far provided no evidence and
Saudi Arabia's ambassador to the US has
called the claim absolutely false and
baseless in an interview with The
Washington Post Jamal has shocked jeeze
fiance said he was worried that
something might happen if he entered the
Saudi consulate fears for his safety had
already seen Jamal has Shoji go into
self-imposed exile in the u.s. last year
what worrying me the most is one my role
he was an outspoken critic of Saudi
Arabia's powerful Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman he felt he needed to leave
Saudi Arabia where he was specifically
ordered to refrain from making any
statements on politics of Saudi Arabia
Saudi Arabia's crown prince has launched
a series of social reforms in the
ultra-conservative Islamic Kingdom we
come
including finally allowing women to
drive in an interview with Norah
O'Donnell for 60 minutes he criticized
hardline interpretations of Islam are
women equal to men abolition absolutely
we are all human beings and there's no
difference but at the same time the
Saudi authorities have cracked down on
all forms of dissent locking up critics
and rights campaigners the United
Nations Human Rights office said today
that if the reports of Jamal has showed
his death are true it is quote truly
shocking Nora all right Holly Williams
in Istanbul thank you and we will
continue to cover this story